just because Peter Parker's Aunt May is
getting on a bit doesn't mean she's
boring
in fact there's much more to May than
just a mean batch of wheat cakes from
her humble beginnings to a big-screen
debut and everything in between
here's the untold story of Marvel's most
iconic golden oldie officially Mae and
Ben Parker made their canonical debut
alongside spider-man an amazing fantasy
number 15
but spider-man's origin story wasn't the
first time that the characters had
graced the pages of a Marvel comic a
couple of months before spider-man's big
entrance Stan Lee and Steve Ditko
published the short story called goodbye
to Linda Brown in strange tales number
97 which featured early versions of both
appears relatives goodbye to Linda Brown
is only a few pages long and doesn't
leave much room for character
development but both Ben and may show
glimmers of their future selves for one
they look very similar to their amazing
fantasy counterparts especially May for
some reason the colorist decided to give
Ben a gray mustache although Ditko
clearly didn't pencil one in in addition
both characters spend most of their time
fretting over a teenager with secret
superpowers which is pretty much all
Aunt May did for the first 50 issues or
so of the amazing spider-man luckily
things did get a little more interesting
after that most fans probably saw Aunt
May in the flesh for the first time in
Sam Raimi's 2002 spider-man movie in
which Peter Parker's doddering aunt was
played by Emmy winning actress rosemary
Harris but Harris wasn't actually the
first person to bring made to life in a
live-action project that honor goes to
Jeff Donnell and so were clear Jean
Marie Donnell went by her nickname Jeff
so that explains that anyway she
portrayed Aunt May in a 90-minute TV
movie that served as the backdoor pilot
for the 1977 spider-man television
series Donnell only played Aunt May and
the spider-man pilot for Mays later
appearances the role was assumed by a
number of different actresses including
reoccuring Dennis the Menace star Irene
Tedrow and of course many actresses
tackled the role of Aunt May in the
world of animation before Harrison
mortalized her on the big screen
June 4 a voiced may and spider-man and
his amazing friends in which Spidey and
company operated out of maze Queens face
to bow but you probably know for a
better as the original voices of both
rocky the flying squirrel and is our
nemesis Natasha fatale in terms of early
spider-man stories you won't find much
that's more iconic than the amazing
spider-man number 33 this comic titled
the final chapter isn't actually
co-creator Steve Ditko's final passage
spider-man but it does feel like an end
of an era and it puts Aunt May front and
center of the story as the issue opens
Aunt May lies at a hospital bed dying
from a transfusion of Peter Parker's
radioactive blood the only cure is an
isotope known as ISO 36 which is
contained in an underwater lab
controlled by spider-man's arch-nemesis
Doctor Octopus the to fight and destroy
the lab and as it fills with water
spider-man is pinned underneath multiple
tons of fallen steel with no hope of
escape the following four pages are
arguably Ditko's finest work in any
spider-man comic at least that's what
Stanley thinks Lee later said it was one
of my all-time favorite stories it was
such a thrill even to me and I was the
writer of the story when I saw that I
almost shouted in triumph Steve did a
wonderful job and who does Peter have to
thank for his big moments well Ditko of
course but also Aunt May as the water
rises spider-man thinks about his
beloved aunt and how he's failed her in
the past namely by letting an anonymous
robber get away leaving him free to kill
her husband been using may strength and
resilience as motivation
Peter lifts the steel beams above his
head and escapes he delivers the isotope
to the hospital in the nick of time and
with meit cured puts the specter of
Uncle Ben's death behind him once and
for all
the scene is so iconic that it plays out
on the big screen
- and spider-man homecoming the amazing
spider-man number 121 in which the Green
Goblin kills Peter Parker's girlfriend
Gwen Stacy is arguably one of the most
important and notorious superhero comics
ever published but it almost played out
very very differently originally Gwen
Stacy was going to make it to the end of
the issue alive and well while Aunt May
was to meet her demise at the goblins
hands instead that revelation comes from
none other than longtime spider-man
artist John Romita senior who Co plotted
the issue with writer Gerry Conway while
talking to CBR Romita confessed that he
and not Conway or artist Gil Kane was
Gwen Stacy's real murderer the original
plan was the sacrifice Aunt May - the
Green Goblin
but ramita pushed back on the idea
claiming that it would actually make the
amazing spider-man less dramatic Romita
explained it'll lose one of Peter
Parker's hang-ups he won't have to worry
about Aunt May anymore he won't be
treated like a child anymore if we want
to make any kind of stir in the monthly
line we have to kill somebody important
and so ramita explained the victim had
to be one of the stories leading female
figures from there when Stacy became the
obvious choice at the time Mary Jane was
what ramita called
an airhead comedy character but when
Stacy was the love of Peter Parker's
life in order to wring the maximum
amount of emotional turmoil out of the
story when has go and the rest of course
is history Aunt May's abilities aren't
limited to simply fretting about the
well-being of superheroes though in fact
she's also a superhero herself
sort of in what-if number 23 a backup
feature called what if Aunt May instead
of her nephew Peter had been bitten by
that radioactive spider tells the story
of bount it's kind of obvious isn't it
an amazing fantasy number 15 Peter
attends a scientific demonstration where
he crosses paths with the fateful
radioactive spider in what if number 23
he leaves his bagged lunch at home and
at may rushes to the Science Institute
to deliver it while she's there the
spider bites May on the hand and her
spider powers kick in on the walk home
may quickly shows herself a costume and
creates a unique version of spider-man's
web fluid out of some over yeasted dough
before long she's taken to the streets
as spider-man juggling her
crime-fighting career with her familial
responsibilities and while what if
stories aren't canonical writer Christos
Gage and artist Dave Williams made
spider-man a reality and spider-man
team-up number three part of Dan Slott
and Olivier COI Pels dimension-hopping
epic spider-verse
in the comic a team of spider-man
including the Peter Parker we know and
love traveled to earth 31:23 to rescue
spider-man from Karn an interdimensional
hunter with a mad hatred for everything
spider related the team is successful
but the battle leads to a dramatic
development in spider-man's story she
finally reveals her secret identity to
her husband and nephew whose lives are
changed forever
the list of people who have stopped
Galactus Marvel Comics gargantuan
devourer of
world's is pretty short the Fantastic
Four are done its of course so if Thanos
the Silver Surfer and the Beyonder and
Aunt May wait what this tale took place
in Marvel team-up number 137 which was
part of Marvel's assistant editors monk
an event during which some of Marvel's
top creators were given free reign to
tell the wildest and silliest stories
they could imagine in the comic
spider-man and the Fantastic Four head
off to San Diego to thwart an unnamed
disaster leaving Reed Richards and Sue
Storm super-powered son Franklin in Aunt
May's care unfortunately just after the
real heroes leave town Galactus arrives
in search of a new Herald and he's got
his sights set on Franklin one lll aimed
energy blast later and Aunt May is
transformed into the golden oldie a
glowing super heroine infused with the
power cosmic I believe there's a hero in
all of us that keeps us honest gives us
strength
thanks to Galactus all of Aunt May's
health problems her arthritis for
vitamin deficiencies her bingo addiction
are gone but there's a catch Galactus is
hungry and it's up to his Herald to keep
him fed at Franklin's prompting Mae
feeds Galactus a Twinkie he loves it and
demands more using her newfound powers
Mae scours first earth than the entire
galaxy for more of the spongy
cream-filled snack cakes on her travels
she meets an alien that looks
suspiciously like the Pillsbury Doughboy
who just happens to make planets that
resemble hostess products at Mae's
suggestion Galactus takes the alien on
as his new Herald and fries made from
her responsibilities when she returns
home Franklin absorbs all of May's
cosmic powers and everything goes back
to normal right before rider Michael
Carlin reveals that the whole adventure
was just the bad dream
or was it Peter Parker will always be
the main man in Mae Parker's life but
with such a busy day to day life May's
nephew doesn't always have time for his
beleaguered aunt thankfully despite her
age Mae is incredibly popular with the
fellas and has accumulated quite a
collection of dudes to keep her company
while Peter's away there was Ben Parker
of course who met his tragic demise in
amazing fantasy number 15 but before Ben
and May got hitched
she almost married a criminal named
Johnny Jerome who tried to win her heart
with money
and who returned to play kur in the
spectacular spider-man annual number
four in the amazing spider-man number 54
Doctor Octopus rents maze spare room and
Windsor over with his charms and in the
amazing spider-man number 131 he
actually tries to marry her in order to
steal her inheritance
although hammerhead and spider-man
interrupt the wedding before it becomes
official great it's live throughout the
80s may dated Nathan Levinsky
a reformed gambling addict who asked me
to marry him before he relapsed fell
afoul of the vulture and died an amazing
spider-man number 336 in the early 90s
she enjoyed a brief fling with the
Fantastic Four's longtime mailman Willie
Lumpkin after Peter Parker and Aunt May
moved to stark tower in the build-up to
Civil War
man Tony Stark's Butler Jarvis shared a
mutual attraction finally Mae dated and
married J jonah Jameson's father John
Jameson senior and stayed with him until
he died of a rare hereditary disease in
the amazing spider-man vol 4 number 19
Aunt May actress rosemary Harris was 75
in 2002 and Sam Raimi spider-man hit
theaters when she appeared his may and
the amazing spider-man Sally Field was
66
by contrast Marisa Tomei who plays Mei
in the modern MCU was only 50 when she
first started as Peter Parker's favorite
aunt
that's significantly younger than May is
usually portrayed in civil war Tony
Stark even jokes about it who else knows
anybody nobody not even your unusually
attractive him but don't blame Tom a
while appearing on The Late Show with
Stephen Colbert Tomei revealed that she
actually petitioned Marvel to make May
into a senior citizen just like in the
comics but the studio declined I
actually made a case to go with to age
me up but nothing no besides as Civil
War co-writer Stephen McFeely has
explained a younger Aunt May makes
perfect sense
given that Tom Hollands Peter Parker is
still in high school McFeely told the
Los Angeles Times that's partly why his
aunt isn't 80 years old if she's the
sister of his dead mother why does she
have to be two generations ahead in
other words the MC use Aunt May isn't
too young at all in the comics she's
actually way too old check out one of
our newest videos right here Plus even
more
for videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you